we just
my hair is blue
foreign
drink a warning
hear us right now
it's my culture
can we offer
this
is
oh
right
i'm the next one
we
i'm
dot com
um
that's called the uh oh i was worried
the sound was acting weird oh man
that's called an i'm already winded
slurp because uh we had some technical
we did we cannot confirm nor deny
that uh uh chris cuomo hacked our
tricaster ah i'm still investigating
it's not impossible wow with naked yoga
he must know he did downward dog
on our sound board
is that or oh is that
sticky so look we have a lot to talk
about today the shooting that happened
yesterday we have some updates on that
something that just happened yesterday
uh we caught it when it had about 42
views
uh the jury video of nbc producers
following the jury oh wow uh of course
there's an update on chris cuomo santa
is black we're going to go through that
we have a lot to get to but let me just
take the theme today
is
lying
and not only lying but you'll see it
with chris cuomo a lot of people are
missing some details here and we'll
refresh your memory um
but same thing with the jury issue nbc
msnbc it's continually lying when you
don't need to lie and lies that are so
egregious
it's not about the lie it's about the
fact that these people fear no
accountability whatsoever sometimes you
have to say well a second why did you
that was a complaint why did you have to
lie that's a completely unnecessary lie
it's because it's what they do and how
many lies led up to that lie same thing
with chris cuomo same thing that we're
going to go through with following the
jury in the kyle rittenhouse trial and
these are lies by the way that people
say words are violence yeah these are
lies that are uh sometimes actual crimes
actual violence
like sexually assaulting women yeah the
brothers cuomo that's what they are
they're like they're like they're like
the van helsing
of sexual assault like a tag team
and then the lie with nbc following a
jury trying to dox a jury
these lies actually harm people what's
that baggy there dave don't show that on
air no all right well before we get to
it it's a colostomy thing something
about
well let's just make sure it doesn't
make you too groggy okay
pass that around gerald a you want some
how are you i am doing well still
illegal to follow a jury bus right i
don't know i know it's illegal to
intimidate a jury and i'm not sure if
being a national producer following them
running red lights would qualify
okay so fine line there it's all about
as a left would say nuance and by the
way that often means gray area so i can
lie
so how how are you sir i'm all right i'm
all right i'm glad we got the audio i'm
glad we got chris come on with the chris
cuomo gremlins out of the technical side
well we can either confirm nor deny all
those
allegedly allegedly allegedly by the way
christian
allegedly grabbed his executive
producer's ass in front of her husband
at a party ah what's up with these cnn
parties wait did i say allegedly you no
absolutely yeah definitely sorry yeah he
admitted to it no no this was this oh
that chris did that yeah chris did it
chris they both they both did it with
his brother what do you mean what's
going on come on cnn we know exactly
what's going on quarter black how are
you sir she's being facetious how are
you good i'm doing good are you wearing
the hat yeah right self-conscious no did
you get a perm yeah and it takes a
little while to set okay i don't want to
tell everybody when you go to his you go
to his house at night he looks like the
granny in bugs but i got waves
waves go there and he will be performing
december 17th through 18th the funny
bone in syracuse new york get your
tickets dave landau
ahoy and i just found out helium new
year's eve no follow well that sounds
like absolute health and more uh
it does before we move on especially now
with twitter's policies they just banned
by the way andy no he's done on twitter
is he well i mean how do you
you think that the antifa rioters are
gonna give consent is he the gay asian
yes that's true yeah white supremacist
what's the premise gay asian i just
wanted to make sure enough synonyms the
gay the reason the banjo player had to
leave mumford inside yes
yeah yeah
i guess
time
and
i uh there's like a few millennials who
remember mumford and sons one song i do
i played a million times i know it was
the ultimate pub song look so i say this
because of twitter's policy youtube
if this show if you don't see it
streaming on youtube it is streaming
monday through thursday every week at 10
a.m eastern you can watch it on mug club
you can watch it on rumble we do another
hour on mug club today we'll be playing
they don't make them like they used to
with play misti for me
women get the crap eaten out of them
justifying in the show rightfully so
i will say yeah yeah yeah this is and
you'll understand when you watch it you
think oh that's offensive no no no
you'll you'll see
so before we get to that a lot to get to
today it's kind of a hodgepodge and any
breaking news mission control will let
us know because we're getting new
information about michigan we're getting
new information about uh uh chris
cuomo's penis yes
i hope not before that liz
and let me ask you you guys comment
below
have you ever been around someone who
lie so often
that this just becomes a part of who
they okay let me can i go off the road
this is good this is and by the way if
you have kids watching this is a story
i'm not going to be profane but it's a
true story
i had a friend in high school and i've
told this before it's been a couple of
years i have a friend in high school who
was a compulsive liar and he lived next
to another friend of mine and he said he
came into the cafeteria one day
and i should probably shouldn't use his
name uh calvin calvin
and he came in one day and he said hey
guys
this weekend i saw
uh your friend let's call him derek i
saw derek uh i could see him through his
window
you know playing with him playing with
himself for like an hour and a half he
was like what a loser and uh first off
we didn't i thought it was a lie because
this guy said he could hard flip nose
grind ready everything he had three
motorcycles i thought it was a lie about
an hour and a half girlfriend from
canada yeah well
that was what i said to him i said look
calvin what even if it's true what
dustin did is normal it's natural what
you did is not yeah derek it's a dare
wrong what did i say dust well now they
different names now they know oh no
you're sitting there like it's
disturbing
yeah it's got binoculars
but that's what happens with compulsive
liars they don't even think through the
lie like chris cuomo i'll be honest i
would lie here and there because the cop
would say how much have you had to drink
and i would say two beers right
it's just a migraine medicine yeah so
there's 12 that is i will let you read
the labels so liz before we get to any
of that lizzo
uh who is by the way
a hugely successful music artist yeah
massively
gigantic on uh
rotundally successful i would say
obesely
successful yeah
poorly
successful
morbidly successful yes yeah uh
difficult difficulty in walking level
of success
has already she's she's already decided
to expand her
expand her uh already expanding horizons
into
painting
oh hey y'all it's your girl lizzy
picasso here you already know that's
ambitious
i'm coming to art basel
at least she's clothed
this is why you didn't show me the clip
before stop
oh
oh
no the first time i'm seeing it
how is this okay she's so happy about it
i thought this was a wholesome video
lizzo
oh my god
it was great up until that point oh like
i genuinely i thought it was just oh
yeah i thought it was going to be like
you know where you do your hand and a
turkey and in her case it would look
like it would look like veal
so it's three or three globes she
painted
i mean
was that what was i looking at i'm
looking at a small screen was that a
globe i don't i don't i don't i don't
really know why
compass won't help you what is this i
mean like think about where we went from
from beetles it was considered risque i
wanna hold your hand i'ma paint with my
ass i'm as good as picasso van gogh
ain't got nothing on me
yeah elvis shaking his hips it was like
burn the tv right and now we're like
what a hero yes
how beautiful and brave
i'll buy that painting i just watched it
back i think it might have been lips
that she painted and so then it's like
someone's kissing her ass ah all right
thank you what is it
do what you want to do
i don't see it again oh why well you
know exactly why let's just add some
happy trees yes yes those trees are
desperate oh that part or right before i
don't it's like that's lips on the page
there i guess these are lips maybe
by the way the paintbrush that you have
to use on her butt is commonly used for
siding on houses yeah
do you need a quart no probably a gallon
yeah it's going to take a little bit
it's the bear in the big blue house
let's just buy bear paint it just makes
sense
what are you painting a bus
man how much blue paint do you need oh
are you doing an entire smurfs movie
it's the only if she were to do an
accurate to scale clifford you would
have to downsize
not a joke now you're making fun of her
because of her weight no no yes yes
yes why because everyone has to phrase
this now we just talked about it
yesterday right again it's a lie it's oh
there's anti-obesity i was on mud club
for people are confused anti-obesity
bias in the medical field do you mean
medicine
to be the largest contributing factor to
being healthy or not i mean that's what
medicine is like don't take too calm in
the morning oh lizzo uh take 19 call me
in the morning i don't know do we have
an elephant blow gun can we
can you imagine an art auction where
it's like this is a lost drawing from
rembrandt
it is worth 1.5 billion dollars founded
a yard sale yes and then next up we have
lizzo's ass prince yes yes followed by
hunter biden's cocaine bender yes
little-known story about lizzo later in
her life she cut off her ear not because
she was deaf to hear vibrations of the
piano through the floor she crashed yes
the breeder triangle they needed to feed
the fleet for a week also the feet were
gone from diabetes yes yes diabetes she
just didn't mail them to anyone because
they were a hazard and uh they were
accidentally sold at a chinese wet
market as bulk feet
easily mistaken because we don't judge
cultures here yes
shooter with a tranquilizer
i don't feel [ __ ] picasso don't it don't
work out
that's right away she compares herself
to picasso
you got a dirty neck yeah that's not
uh it's like
oh
that's well even yeah what is the
picasso even related to it's like have
you seen a picasso painting it's the
only artist she could think of like
painting yeah picasso i don't know she's
a picasso was she doing an ass face like
picasso abstract i gotta ask where face
is the face where ass
can you imagine the turkey hand print
though if she did do it it's just like
two fingers and this before it runs out
of canvas that's what she was painting
yeah turkey just a big ass turkey gobble
gobble thank you why
what segment of the population wants to
see this is too many too much this is a
serious
never mind
i was gonna say serious quandary you
know you know how we always look back
right on fossils yeah and they say this
is you know this is sort of the
transition fossil and you always wonder
like what if they okay so they will
often tell you because of you know uh
biological evolution that we have bigger
heads now because we have a bigger brain
you know whereas they used to be bigger
they used their t our teeth used to be
different depending on whether we were
in agrarian society or we were nomadic
okay what do you think would happen in
200 years if they find a fossil of lizzo
look as you can see here uh you know
entirely different we believe that this
uh large hump was to preserve water and
air into regions yes
i think the way things are going
nobody's gonna be able to have any
strength to dig
like gigantic people sitting around
going i wish we still looked as fit yes
i wish we still did
if she does downward dog and walks you
could have lawrence of arabia riding
like a camel and knowing when he was
like oh yeah that's the water hump okay
so am i quite i have another question
for you before we get to it
what do you think because right now
before the bodies are even cold what do
you think we need to do about
when people talk about mass shootings
genuinely because i hear a lot of people
proposing solutions that i don't think
they believe would work now i'm not
saying that more guns will reduce mass
shootings that's that's not our argument
people on the right are not saying hey
you're going to eliminate all violence
if you allow people the right to protect
themselves we are saying that in the
face of violence human beings have the
right to protect themselves the
solutions coming from the left after
michigan don't make any sense
unless you believe that you can make all
of america a gun-free zone and i'll get
to that in a second but first chris
cuomo he was suspended indefinitely oh
no oh no
think about this for a second
foreign is back i know
yeah tuban works couple of cuban is back
and chris cuomo so if they if if they
still have tubin on cnn then what chris
did must be really bad well he could be
coming back we'll see so human only
assaulted himself yeah
yes
and everybody else he was aggressive
about it oh yeah like too you can
masturbate on a zoom call but you have
to keep slamming your testicles in the
drawer
who works there it's like come on guys
we've all masturbated on these zoom
calls i mean you know like guys this
isn't the first time who among us
come on just hit the mute button problem
solved
pot calling the kettle master baby
come on tuban just
the end of the day grab some cognac
relax go on the subway with a trench
coat do it like the rest of us
a good
like
new
good new yorker because that's an
interpol song new york yes
subway she is a cuomo oh jeez
uh it was a great album okay so he was
suspended indefinitely for uh chris
cuomo for digging here's the thing
everyone knew that he was helping his
brother right but he was suspended
because they found out that he was
digging up dirt on the legitimate
accusers of sexual assault from andrew
cuomo so here's a statement the new york
attorney general's office released
transcripts and exhibits monday that
shed new light on chris cuomo's
involvement in his brother's defense we
also appreciated the unique position he
was in this is from cnn and his need to
put family first and his job second and
then later they said however these
documents point to a greater level of
involvement in his brother's efforts
than we previously knew as a result we
have suspended chris indefinitely
pending further evaluation
um i want to be clear about something
here
i
i get it i don't think this is the worst
thing that chris cuomo has done now he
if my brother for example were in
trouble and i had the ability to help
him on the show i can't really put
myself in his shoes because i wouldn't
help him dig dirt up on people that he
allegedly you know raped sexually
assaulted but then again i haven't also
sexually assaulted people both brothers
have so that's something that i will not
defend but i do understand and kind of
respect being
loyal to your brother to a degree the
issue here
is not only did chris cuomo lie about
this chris cuomo lies about
everything now what do i mean by this
so what did he lie about he lied about
uh the lockdown remember he was out
riding his bike
he lied about that uh he lies about the
weights that he lifts
uh he lied about fredo being a
well-known uh a slur against the italian
people yeah this is somebody who's part
of two just like the interest not it's a
slur against you yes exactly it's like
the n word it's not even a slur if it's
appropriate because you are the brother
of a criminal family and you're the
worst one yeah you're afraid it really
does fit yes it really does andrew would
whack you in a boat right if they were
to remake the godfather the casting
sheet would read for fredo a chris cuomo
type yes
find us at chris cuomo i believe if you
look at the original script it does say
say that yeah it was a scratched out
chris sorry i mean fredo
and he lied about he also lied about
this is something that seems
inconsequential but it's not
he lied about his dunk and what do i
mean by this
and you can go back to the segment
because we found the actual basketball
hoop that he did
disprove and we fruit
he went out of his way to tell people
that he was dunking on a 10-foot rim
uploaded it
and then argued with people as to its
legitimacy
in the comment section yeah but i think
the fisher price logo is what gave it
away yeah
it was a four in one table yeah look air
hockey yeah
it's that yellow plastic hoop
and he's got a hat trick yes here's the
thing about this though think about it
no one was saying bet you can't dunk on
a 10-foot rim yeah i can't it was he
decided his head popped off the pillow
oh i'm gonna lie about this and then
defend it he didn't need to lie he
decided to go out and lie and then
defended the lie
vigorously that is
that is a a pathology and so sometimes
people skim past past oh no if he's
lying about these things there's no
reason to lie what is he doing
with the topics with the subjects when
he hosts a news program and his
brother's governor how is he treating
the issues that actually matter where he
stands to gain from that lie so uh he
did have a great run at cnn and we're
going to lose some material for segments
yeah um but of course uh chris cuomo the
lesser cuomo
it's time to close
just looking out of the window
watching the asphalt grow
how do you know the words the good times
you know i'm black on the inside time to
close
endings and beginnings are
i thought i did so well on that nasal
test standing up there she did the swab
i did not flinch i was a cool dude in a
loose mood punk ass [ __ ] from the
right call me fredo my name is chris
cuomo my fredo is from the godfather it
was a weak brother it's an insulting
people it's like the n word for us
uh yes it is like the n word for
no one
i can't wait to do john lemmons oh yeah
it's coming up oh it's going to be a
good closing time well by the way did
you notice
brian stelter didn't defend chris cuomo
at all oh no he did read the statement
this morning but that was it uh
yesterday i think oh he did it this
morning too oh did he well that's even
worse he went back you know he's back
i'm gonna get the prime time
i'm gonna love my pre-show pump yes
i would never sexually assault a woman
no no
this video has been wiped from the
internet his wife was doing yoga and he
just walked he just strolled
now let me be clear i have no problem
with a guy being naked at his house okay
if anyone ever says hey this uh pictures
of steve and crowd are naked at his
house probably me
we can look at the ass i would certainly
definitely sorry i mean it could be
anybody who knows
there's naked dudes in my house all the
time it could be anybody with incision
scars from titanium rods that replace
them it's a common procedure
it's the fact that that was again the
lack of accountability that that was
either streamed or uploaded and someone
said sure yeah they'd have a problem
with it for like a day until someone
said that's a naked cuomo
there's a cuomo in the back
and i don't think that was an accident
no that he went in front of the camera
no i don't know he's trying to show off
it wasn't a wide angle lens he had to
pick his but he had to hit a mark yeah
he probably fluffed it and was like i
hope it catches them
yes but i am uh often naked at my house
one time i was in the backyard and uh
betty uh we had this bullfrog that would
jump in the pool and i it was dark it
was at night
so betty jumps in the pool after this
bullfrog and she's i realize she's the
the bullfrog sorry is down at the bottom
of the pool and she is uh just swimming
in a circle and her head is going lower
and lower and yeah we're into the water
will not get out so i flip on the porch
light at this point i have my firearm at
my keys and i just go like uh i can't i
just drop my pants and jump in to grab
betty and my neighbor's like hey what's
going on over there and i'm walking with
a wet dog and my penis
it's like i had too much in my pockets
and i still had socks well i still had
socks the funny thing is you turned
around and stood there and said it you
could have kept walking i waited for a
good half hour for my neighbor to show
up
yeah you're just holding
he's never gonna believe this
hey art
it's better you're wet than just holding
a jar of peanut butter right hey
neighbor
oh what are you doing there uh
training
you never know don't be judgmental it's
generational okay
so now we're going to move on speaking
of lying to nbc it's not just cnn
everyone here remember the story of nbc
msnbc
wmsnbc following
the bus
or the bus the van of the cal britain
house jurors yes so we covered that we
actually uh i believe we were the at
least we broke it on air at this point
it wasn't widely assembled i don't know
if we were the people to find the
producer uh irene uh bayan uh the asian
lady but uh
it was pretty bad when you heard the
story but just last night the police
camera footage yes was released and
here's what i want again i want you to
watch this see if you can in real time
spot the lie there's a lot first off you
can just hear in the voice that it's it
it's like a kid who got caught yeah or
like a guy with a peanut butter
you just at certain points you go uh
yeah nothing it's like a naked man
holding a wet dog oh yeah like a naked
man holding a wet dog with a bullfrog
hanging from his teeth
what was this not normal
everybody come on hey yeah so who among
us come on
me i have not i am the woman oh oh well
you must be very proud of yourself i i
can't wait till that we find out the
real jared yeah there's a gerald rolled
i don't go by that have you not known
his name this whole time i know his name
that's why i call him jared okay
well if we want to lots we want to if we
want a bull crap story we went to jared
did you see them
i lied
that was a good one i know it's gerald
it's pretty it's cheryl day nope he's
gerald uh i see jared because he reminds
me of the subway guy oh that's better
it doesn't help that every morning you
come in and hold up your pants well yeah
you show everybody you're like look dave
i thought it was the [ __ ] look how
thinner i am than you
i gave it away and then you eat a
12-inch sub in two bites yeah i don't
know how he does it's a skill
astonishing
like scooby doo or a
good actress dave does this turn you on
yeah why and why when you why wouldn't
you swallow the footlong meatball sub do
you go
yeah it's crazy i don't know you shove
it meatballs like a deck of cards those
things are tasty i ate a foot long
pastrami on rye why joints maybe stop
going through the fridge at the haunted
house yeah donor
get your [ __ ] together
all right paula okay so the body cam
footage from the police this is nbc a
producer following the jury van
i want you to see if you can spot the
lie in real time here we go uh
what significance have you been here
new york told you to follow a vehicle
yes
your office is in new york or what
that's right how did they know about
this vehicle
i mean it was discreet i wasn't like
talk to anybody
just trying to find a location that's
awesome
can you hear me i can hear you now
okay hi officer my name is irene i'm a
booking producer with nbc news
um we
we were just trying to respectfully um
just trying to see if it's
if it's possible to
um
to find any leads about um
about
the case and so we were we
were just keeping our distance
just to see like where
um
people involved in the in the trial
are positioned
are we trying to get in contact with any
of any of the jury members or whoever's
in the car we just were
trying to see like where um
key players in the trial may be asked
all right so
real quick how you advised him to follow
uh
like any vehicle did you know which
vehicle he was following
um
we're going to ask you guys to not do
that
yeah listen listen i asked you this is a
law enforcement professional
don't be an [ __ ] um yeah not your
whole life not your whole life she can't
even make anything up though no she's
just a stammering lying it's painfully
obvious and and you're just admitting to
putting people ed in danger right and
she said she doesn't she says when you
had them positioned to follow key
players to see where they and then she
said you know we were just following
anybody no you just said that you knew
they were key players okay and now you
say you didn't know and so
and also it's easy to fact check that
lie did they follow anyone else who was
not the not the jurors hey where are the
investigative journalists oh right
they're banned from twitter hey so
mission control actually just sent me a
snips fact check and any guesses as to
what they said uh let me guess that it's
false that nbc followed the jury van so
not exactly they actually said for the
claim in november 2021 an msnbc producer
intentionally followed a bus containing
chairs in the murder shelf of cal ring
house
unproven that's odd what they said what
they said was in a statement provided to
cnn's brains still turned by msnbc they
saw stealth reliable sources right last
night a freelancer received a traffic
citation while the traffic violation
took place near the jury van the
freelancer never contacted or intended
to contact the jurors during
deliberations and never photographed or
intended to photograph them but that's
not what the claim was about yeah they
claim it was about they found them
trying to follow a bus yeah look
everyone right now here's what i'm gonna
ask you to do smash the like button on
youtube
to confirm that you are going to send a
letter to snopes let's have mission
control find a complaint or a tip line
smash the like button so i know how many
thousands of you right now are going to
put pressure on snopes that's it's not
only a lie it's a lie with documentation
now i hope they change it in the face of
the because what they just said yeah
first off wasn't addressing the claim
and it's wrong as you see on the police
camera footage yeah well one of the
things you need to look at there they
said it was key players but then she
also said jury members as well you know
she was talking about jury members the
whole time but the thing that bothers me
is they they ask okay how did you know
which which bus to follow
like how did you know how to do this how
did they happen if there was one did
they just sit outside and watch the bus
leave and they were following the entire
time what are you okay so fine you're
following the bus with no intention to
contact anybody or photograph anything
respect then why the hell are you
following us here's here well only one
of two reasons well
doxing what's obvious or or because
you're not allowed to interview anyone
related related to the case at all
during that trial yeah right or the
juries i should the jury members i
should say i think because grosskritz
was everywhere with his lawyer just
completely indicted himself pretty much
with that 10 million gauge but the thing
here is is um
they i guess were trying to get their
location so they could try to
immediately go after but but here's the
thing the judge and it was well known on
the record that they were trying to get
the jury out of town as quickly as
possible yes so there is no excuse they
knew that this was a safety risk they
knew that the jury knew it was a safety
risk and there's a lot more that we
don't know kind of like the vegas
shooting who tipped off the cops was it
a juror in the van who was concerned how
did they know like you said how did they
know where that uh where where that bus
was how do they know to follow that bus
or that van sorry it's been reported two
different ways and by the way this girl
irene social media is still entirely
wiped what's her employment employment
status with nbc
probably got a bonus hey you did find
the bus apparently sorry you were going
to say something dave but then i cut you
off no i was just saying that obviously
the only reason they would be following
them is to docs where they're at right
right or to gather information on that
which is extraordinarily dangerous yes
yeah and illegal i mean it's illegal to
intimidate a jury i'm not sure if
following uh an
unmarked anonymous car or where they are
trump
yes okay you're right it's illegal yeah
uh it's it is frowned upon yes it's
generally frowned upon listen all they
have to do is master them call all they
have to do is report you right right on
the jury knock knock knock right after
the trial hey why did you vote to uh
acquit kyle rittenhouse oh i looked at a
mountain of evidence well he's a known
white supremacist who he illegally shot
people with a gun and carried across
state lines care to comment right that's
all they have to do and all of a sudden
like you're on your face is on the news
and now the rage mob comes after you yes
i would like to comment irene you're a
horrible [ __ ] and i disrespect you for
this
and for everyone who wants to contact
snopes just go to snopes.com contact
snopes.com contact smash that like
button on youtube right now to let me
know that you're doing it
this is important because this is about
our justice system here we cannot have
like think of think about the
consequences think about the tentacles
of these lies you have a man on thank
god the saving grace here is no one
watches these networks anymore yeah
that's true no one respects them but you
have someone on prime time who if this
country still believed was an actual
news network was doing the bidding for
his brother who was governor of new york
with the single worst coveted response
outside of michigan who actively tried
to cover it up and both committed sexual
assault and recovering up for each other
and then here you have a producer at nbc
and one of her lackeys going out to try
and effectively sway the jury in one of
the most important self-defense trials
of our time think of the consequences of
these lies the media everyone in in
washington dc the entertainment industry
and then people wonder when bernie
sanders says the the system is rigged
it's not because of a guy who owns a few
chuck e cheeses and make it makes a
couple million this year it's because
the fbi the doj the president can go
after kyle rittenhouse the media will
make sure that they try and get the
verdict through intimidation coercion or
any tactic therein and then of course if
you have people who you would criticize
like we have on this show uh your
brother may be hosting a show keep it
you know what we're not allowed to do
this anymore on this channel token owl
and you can confirm gerald you can
confirm we're not allowed to do what a
piece of [ __ ] segments on youtube
we were told
we're not allowed to do a piece of [ __ ]
techniques on youtube anymore there are
a lot of would it apply anymore
no
no they're mad about but also with cuomo
and
cnn going after them
what did they think was gonna happen
while they've pushed this agenda for the
last three years did they really think
that we're one of the good ones was
going to actually work out in their
favor right
that's what photographing right that's
what they're doing though it's like
you're just pushing this agenda that
completely goes against you and
everything you are everything that is
america and then it's like oh they just
kicked me to the curb yeah that was the
goal you dumb [ __ ] yes whoa pardon my
language pardon my language that's okay
to him [ __ ] at least it's not like
the n word to italians oh it is it is i
don't mean i it really is pardon me
fredo
i mean frey does oh i hope this weekend
he has a meeting with a piano wire okay
yesterday former vice president joe
biden he was banging cocktail waitresses
doing it yeah
yesterday former vice president joe
biden um
assured us that we can have total
confidence yes his ability to carry out
his presidential duties when he signed
four bipartisan veteran
bills kind of of consequence so uh it's
time for this week in biden wait if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump then you ain't
black all right
here we go
men title well i'm not going to read it
all
we just signed it
what are we doing
all right if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or trump then
you ain't black but former vice
president didn't have time to read bills
why does he say
l r biden by the way does anybody notice
he doesn't know his name anymore
j r by n his j's just look like l's
that's not a j
that was a straight line your j's look
like else i have a cold therefore your
j's look like else i have a sweater yes
stop it he signs like a pill mill doctor
so he doesn't have to explain himself
later yeah like david doubt i love how
he's like he goes to start reading and
he's like i'm not going to read the
entire thing no you're not going to read
any of that you're not going to read any
of it you didn't read what if it was the
five-page green new deal
you would read less than one-fifth yeah
you didn't read the title yeah you
stopped the title was it words that she
won't sign this you old coot
it's just a picture of kamala harris
yeah
tom selleck comes in a second later and
takes the white house what did i sign
what oh no
you got a good price just a photo booth
uh reel of kamala harris with his with
biden's corpse a skeleton in his wig
25th amendment i just resigned
oh i should have read it yikes
she hits a button and he falls through a
trap door into a furnace
he's just immediately put in a home
it's for your own good joe
it's for your own gut oh it's sad now
i'm picturing him in a courtyard with
you know no one visiting
oh yeah
i was president yeah kind of no you
never believe you're sure you work
okay here's your meds come on man
oh
like father like piece of crap son okay
yes so uh as i'm sure by the way you
know today is december 1st it is
so that marks the start of the national
safe toys and gifts month
apparently toys can be more dangerous
than i realized according to the united
states consumer product safety
commission
251 000 toy-related injuries were
treated by hospital emergency rooms
around the u.s in 2010 i guess wow the
number was so bad they just didn't
they didn't keep down enough yeah yeah
it's gonna get so small
yeah let's be honest 250 000 of them
involved a man's rectum yes
a nurse i'm like what's the weirdest
thing you found inside it oh yeah
oh yeah yeah and they will tell how much
time stories yeah yeah i've had barbie
doll i forgot
how did you get the dump truck in there
you know what i have amazing i don't
know if i should tell us i feel like
this shows let's not be too dirty i
don't think it's dirty i don't think
it's dirty okay
one of my relatives
yeah do you know what she found if you
have kids they shouldn't listen to this
i'm not going to swear but it's gross
fire hose
that perforated the rectum oh oh no
like a fire truck fire hose well i don't
know if it was a fire truck fire hose or
like civil rights with german shepherds
fire hose but it was a firehouse yes
what did they think would happen yeah i
don't know that thing's got blasting
power that's unbelievable i know i mean
i called it a day with the super soaker
3000.
oh believe me
but then i was light as a feather so
what are you doing just playing with the
dangerous
it's time for my colonic
stop it tubing
it's just filled with vodka i'm gonna
get so drunk
all i knew was a kid who had someone can
tell me i think it was a super sucker
two thousand super five thousand i know
when you're talking about whoever had it
you were like your parents are rich oh
yeah exactly i had the original super
soaker yeah and then i had the one that
added the ball on the i had the ball on
that one too and i would just take it
off and throw it at people because it
sucked it didn't do anything no it was
supposed to be like extra and it was
also extra ammo in there if this was a
real fight i'd be dead the one that
could squirt that could go around
corners no oh i did yeah and the first
thing i did i had the nerf gun that
didn't it wasn't rich that wasn't that
wasn't even that big
it was just richer than me
you could you could go around corners
and me and basically and it broke after
two minutes and i remember the first
thing it was like i filled it up yeah
people out there do you remember this
superstar
on course so i filled it up and i was
like hey dad and i aimed it here and i
went
and my dad's like oh oh it looks like
you're going to shoot that tree there oh
no
he's a great dad yeah then he beat me
yeah no i'm sure a super soaker got me a
weapon once or twice in my day yeah yes
got a fire hose up the uh oh all those
toys even the slip and slide and now i
guess they don't have the hooks that
they used to have oh yeah they were
they're basically the magical metal
metal tent hooks yeah but if you slip
off the side
we actually set it up in our yard where
we only had room for it to go into a
pricker bush
and no one cared we just did it we were
just like oh i heard you come out with a
beard
that was so fun for two and a half
seconds before i impaled myself kids
don't know anymore how dangerous these
toys were it was like with my dad he
would use him to punish me if i act it
up he'd make me go play lawn darts in a
thunderstorm like squid game well it's
like that old uh snl sketch with dan
aykroyd when he's like it's bag of glass
it's bag of glass yeah i said what kids
like glass they pick it up everywhere
now it's just a bag of glass funny thing
is you actually do it better than dan
aykroyd so thank you yeah i do not like
that
no no have you met him no i just mean he
takes himself so seriously now oh i
don't think he i think he's so mentally
gone yeah yeah he's like he started
selling crystals to anyway okay so it's
safe toy month
and one person who might want to pay
special attention speaking of lies the
lies now what they go into the medical
field so when people say it's a culture
awards no no no it's a lie that is
agreed upon and you are now going to
determine what to do you are now going
to determine what language we're allowed
to use and i know you're saying well
stephen you're going too far to make a
point no not internationally respected
newspaper
and what i'm going to read all
references available at ladarcutter.com
this is not a photoshop
you wouldn't believe me if i could
travel in time
just to
the first two years of obama's
presidency where he was against gay
marriage you would say what this isn't a
real story so
chloe thompson from t uh t side test
side england
thompson was caught using a sex toy and
servicing uh thompson in public this is
what the article reads
she is charged with committing a public
nuisance by indecently exposing her
penis
to other members of the public
wells
wilst masturbating from a property
window i love how they still use it yeah
typing speaking of she's just speaking
of right now on cnn honestly the word
willst is what bothers me most about
that whole thing
that man is charged with publicly
masturbating on a zoom call whilst
eating a peanut butter sandwich
playground in the school
and the worst part was it was crunchy
everyone knows to get in the mood you
must eat smooth
smooth
her penis was flapping betwixt her
thighs
truly vexing me i found myself entranced
by the movement of her member and
swaziland
as she revealed her john thomas i found
myself
warming to the sense of her touch her
motherly penis yes
yes
as i gazed upon her matronly testicles
boys have a penis girls have a bad job
whether i found myself turned off by the
chewing gum on her pubis
gerald and i were looking at that for
the show and just like what why what in
the world like that's just a sentence
and
and lots of people were like yeah that's
good yeah no no no from gazette live the
two words her and penis should never be
that close together this sounds totally
normal i'm just saying people say oh
it's a culture well look
here's the problem is what if it becomes
hate speech and it is yeah to say no
there's no such thing as her penis
i'm taking a risk saying it right now
on youtube just to be clear yeah that
could be depending on who's moderating
that day
could be be a risk could be considered
dead naming oh no there's no such thing
as her penis what what what
it was it was sad it would make it a
line of clothing her penis yes yes penis
yes this is a new trend i used to wear
pants that read juicy upon my upper
thighs but now it's all about her penis
coutures here herpes
yes please i presented
i present to you bishop chick with dick
yes oh oh hello right right right right
all hail the quack the
the thing yes in her all in her
serving in her royal majesty's secret
service uh whatever that is yes
she fell off a horse and her right
testicle was destroyed bravely destroyed
and beautifully
lest we forget her beautiful striking
penis and taint so
does the glass condom fit
we shall fit
better get home before midnight or your
pumpkin will turn into a penis it is
true love yes but she's left her glass
scumbag because the legend says that
only true loves eskimo sheepiness
oh yeah yeah that's absolutely true oh
that's for sure
you don't turn into it yeah when we're
when we're watching the cinderfella
yeah they already have that about
sneakers
they're aristocox
there are no cats anymore it's just
man what did you expect we put it in the
title for roosters meaning to the family
jewels yes
atlantic
the lion [ __ ] i can just oh no we can go
all day yes yes
well the jungle penis yes
it's not even creative
the lion the witch and the transition
surgery doctor
blue is just balls
i can't believe that this is big blue
balls that live in a forest and sing
i've got the ball necessities the simple
ball necessities
did we tape that balloon sketch no no we
didn't never had it i forgot about that
i forgot about that i don't want to ruin
it now oh he was clearly a pedophile oh
he was naked going he was naked
traveling down a river with a boy in a
loincloth telling him he didn't need his
parents he's like why don't you sit on
my stomach and use me as a boat
want to go for a ride
what oh below what are the bear
necessities
quaaludes and astro glide
seems i need quite a bit more than that
maybe some flints
don't you bears like honey yeah yeah
i do yeah all right so i do i bet this
this lady slash man uh
gets his or her toys delivered probably
by norwegian santa yeah that reminds me
today is also national aids day so if
she did get that toy from norwegian
santa she might want to schedule an
appointment at the local clinic also
because norwegian santa you know is a
little bit down on his luck uh
you guys can go to crottershop.com yeah
buy this wonderful che guevara shirt
because we weren't allowed to have the
socialism for fig so we just have jacob
aaron and don's cap oh and also just
reminded me with the dan aykroyd talk
that gay norwegian santa looks just like
dan aykroyd in trading places
and i don't know how i missed that
yesterday yes you're right all right
we're not even going to have time for
the black santa we'll talk about black
san antonio no no let's do it no we'll
talk about it we'll do it tomorrow all
right
uh because we do have to get to this
michigan shooting oh yeah this is more
serious and uh so yesterday and
obviously a tragedy uh three students
were were killed eight were shut i want
to make sure so three students were
killed eight were shot at the time of
this
stream at oxford high school in a suburb
of detroit michigan for those who missed
it so yeah about 15 minutes outside of
pontiac is that it yeah okay here's the
clip the deputies removed from the
suspect
a nine millimeter sig sauer
sp 2022
it was loaded at the time and still
contained seven rounds of ammunition
when they took it from him he had a
loaded firearm and he was coming down
the hall preliminary investigation
revealed that the weapon used in the
shooting was purchased
on november 26th
four days ago
by the boy's father
the gun had a
15 round magazines we found two of them
okay so
a couple let me give you an update on
what we know right now to make sure
you're informed all references are
available at lightworkcredit.com we try
and keep this up to date as well there
are other posts uh the alleged shooter
right now from what we know is 15 year
old ethan crumbly and there were plenty
of warning signs before we get to the
whole gun control situation if you see
the trends that are going on right now
before the bodies assume room
temperature that's what's so criminal
about it
warning signs like crumbly allegedly
posted a countdown to the return of the
devil
uh on his instagram stories uh the bio
um in a second by the way now removed
instagram account
that was suspected to be the shooters uh
it read now i am become death destroyer
of worlds see you tomorrow oxford well i
wouldn't put the name of the school on
that with the grammar that's yeah
they're probably upset about that yeah
the english teacher quote i guess
so uh and here's something else and i
say this when i see a youtube account
believed to be the shooters let me tell
you i don't have this 100 confirmed
here's why we feel 90 something percent
confident that it's from him uh the
videos were on a channel that were named
after him
they have all been since taken down and
third-party sources have confirmed it uh
so feel pretty confident in saying that
this is from the shooter on a youtube
channel where he was posting videos uh
you know
involving molotov cocktails and the like
so again rather than the firearms we
have warning signs from this person i'm
guessing parents not paying attention
even more his fellow students
believed that something was going to
happen before it did here's a clip
something's something's wrong so i'm
like what was worrying everybody there
was there have been some uh some ominous
threats posted in recent days is that
right yeah that is right there it is
i've been hearing the threats too and
it's like you know kids they they play
around and say oh we're going to shoot
up to school
you don't possibly play around with that
like this is serious you can't do that
so i mean like it's a lot of stuff
that's been going on you know this
school has been it's been tragic now we
don't know if it came from the shooter
but there was a probably didn't from
what i understand there was a severed
deer head thrown into uh the school
courtyard and students were concerned to
the school sent out an email that read
there is no present danger sorry no
present threat of danger at oxford high
school and then went on to say before
school began this morning we identified
graffiti on the cement outside our pool
entrance doors a severed deer head is
graffiti well they also i think they
said later it was thrown into
an area that a severed deer head was but
i'm like the graffiti is not the part
that i'm wearing yeah the graffiti
that's like yes
dear head whoever it is not fredo
whoever wakes up with the horse head in
his bed he's like oh
graffiti ah that's an offer i can't
really use it's just so sad though that
you see like this kid on the news who's
saying you know there was warnings of
shooting at the school but kids always
play like that that's just sad that it's
so common yeah that you don't even
consider it a threat well the thing is
exactly someone threw a deer head yeah
at the school severed deer head and they
said well there's no threat of danger
yeah so in other words this school
doesn't seem like they have super tight
security to begin with and students were
recognizing what administrators and
parents failed to
see by the way some
behavior let's just be clear about the
lie like her penis if someone said her
penis right that sort of you know uh
wanting to wear someone's suit as a skin
type behavior yeah we used to be able to
identify certain sets of behaviors and
say this might be disturbing and now you
can't
now you can't molotov cocktail is that
really disturbing if ant but we see aunt
for training with it they say these
people are just they're fighting back
her penis well hold on a second this
might be something indicative of
someone's psyche being no it's beautiful
and brave so we also are
we're self-censoring what's worse than
th this violation the first amendment
which takes place in twitter is with
which they're complicit we talked about
yesterday is the culture of
self-censorship because people are more
afraid of offending
protected groups
in identifying
truly in the words been hijacked
problematic dangerous behavior they're
more afraid to identify it than they are
of the kind of behavior that we've
always known could be dangerous yeah
that's a scary place to be and again it
all starts with a lie and a lie and a
lie and a lie and a lie and a lie and a
lie lie lie lie men and it starts with a
lie that men and women are the same and
it ends with a lie of her penis and
there's nothing about a severed deer
head uh that uh you need to see you
don't want to know anything about that
yeah you think yeah if her penis is
laying out on the football field you
might want to have at least an assembly
right yeah
well somebody so many of the students
knew about this and there's probably
some more that you're going to get to
but i've been trying to kind of skim
through social media and piece together
stuff yeah so many people knew about
this and there were reports that
students stayed home yes that just yeah
like hey i'm not i didn't feel like we
haven't been able to confirm it but it
does seem that it's very there are
reports
that was even yesterday almost
immediately after yeah yeah and there's
also reports that a parent maybe
potentially several parents reached out
to the school to find out what was going
on prior so we haven't confirmed any of
that yet i'm just like there's reports
out there for that right now absolutely
and i think you're right about the
protected group things everybody's
worried about protective groups
protecting these protected groups right
which leads it to
not protecting everyone else right and
that's the problem today you walk into
if you walk into a high school boys room
and see a lit pentagram and a strap-on
and some weed you have to say oh this
all seems like these are equally valid
choices as the alternative
i'm not joking yeah that's not a joke i
mean yes kind of but not really think
about it we're not supposed to judge
anything now this culture of not being
judgmental forces us to put on the
blinders and the truth is we don't
really put on blinders we see it we just
put the tape over our mouths now just
smoke cigarettes in the bathroom like
you should quarters that's what i'm good
at you don't need pills just coffee and
cigarettes cigarettes and numbers if
there's thirty of you doing it that's
gonna stop you and by the way catch you
all kids when you smoke cigarettes don't
you look really cool no that's it
doesn't no you totally it'd be a lot
you want to be really cool you do like a
senior wences with a severe deer head
and you put a couple of marbles in there
hey what do you think oh he's nervous
good lean back smoke a cigarette no seat
belt be awesome kids exactly yeah please
kidding don't do that it's way cooler to
be
lame take off your helmet grab a few
cigarettes get on your ducati see what
it can do now inside the classroom don't
don't do that either
don't no then that guy just says
motorcycle who are you gonna trust me me
or the sound board nine
so this is disturbing there's nothing
graphic but inside the classroom uh
again this is a report kids had to flee
but what you'll see is
the initial reports are that the shooter
tried to impersonate an officer or
someone other than a shooter and i think
what you're seeing is the teacher
sending him away and then the students
had to flee out the window here you go
yes
sheriff's office
come out
yeah he said it safe
now we're not willing to take that risk
right now i can't hear you we're not
taking that risk right now okay well
look at the door look at my bag bro
yeah bro
he said bro
he said bro red flags
yeah come on well you can't do that
that'd be judgmental
slow down you're fine and i will say
they're very lucky that the shooter was
really dumb yeah like land shark well so
i think the the report is that that
actually was a sheriff's deputy that was
trying to get in there
who may have said bro kind of to relate
to what he was yeah well then they're
unfortunate that the sheriff was really
dumb yeah that's not what the kids
thought the kids thought that the
shooter was trying to get into the room
right now yeah but they heard bro and
they said ready for you hey i'm the
county sheriff essay all right get out
the way all right we're in michigan
that's not happening here a lot bothers
me about that reaction though yeah that
the kids were just kind of laughing and
joking around and not letting the girls
out first well that but well i think
they were kind of terrified but i think
i think the sad part is when you hear
the kid going all right guys that's a
red flag like
they're so aware of this now as kids
like i can't imagine ever being in that
situation in high school i just think
people were unaware of it i mean my aunt
got her ged because someone was shot in
the face she went to school in detroit
it was very common i'm not sure where
this correlates no i'm just no i'm
saying they were just weren't aware of
it they didn't have drills oh
oh yeah there were shootings all the
time but i mean the point that there's
these massive school shootings where
kids now have a language for it is
what's scary to me yeah i mean i think
it might have been helpful if you look
at crime statistics if people had that
language back i just think people
weren't as aware of it because columbine
happened when i was a junior in high
school right and the first thing they
did was try to come up with this policy
that if it happens you
get under a desk but that was not the
first we had three mass shootings in
montreal people understand it doesn't
happen outside the united states i don't
remember i think there was there was a
there was one at concordia there was one
at a cal polytechnic where i believe if
i'm not mistaken a guy walked in an
execution style killed like something
teen women something
is somewhere between 12 and 15 i want to
say 12 shot behind the scenes because uh
he thought that he had lost his job
because he was a man and they were
hiring more women with quotas i believe
that and then there was concordia
shooting and then my friends were in a
school uh dawson college when there was
a shooting that went on so there were
plenty of shootings that had taken place
i i think a big part of it is that it
just wasn't uh
they didn't have the timing and the
capability of using it as a political
tool like columbine and this is
something i want to take a moment to
recognize uh the oxford heist uh uh the
uh high school uh football player tate
meyer tried to save everyone just to be
clear
so that's an actual hero tried to disarm
the shooter try to disarm the shooter
not joseph not rob rosa jojo not rosen
not jojo not caitlyn jenner not lizzo
someone who actively put his life in
danger to try and save and he shouldn't
have to now some people on the left will
say we shouldn't have to so we need no
guns here's what i want to get to did he
again and he was like i'm sorry did he
live no he's he's no he's yeah he's
passed yeah passed away trying to
absolutely
uh it's really it's absolutely
heartbreaking um but you know what uh
i hope his hope is if his family is
paying it
hope you are proud i i know it doesn't
it doesn't
ease the pain of these wounds i can't
even imagine no but that's a real hero
and i'm very very sorry for your loss
yeah that's a genuine hero he saved
lives yeah yeah he saved a lot of people
by putting his own at risk
it's absolutely
disgraceful and that actually brings me
to a point
we'll never know how many lives he saved
what do i mean by that how much time did
he buy how many people escaped out the
back door how many people were able to
get out
of the window how many how many deputies
and sheriffs and policemen were able to
get their who knows you're talking about
a game of seconds my friend shale talked
about this in wrestling practice he had
a coach who would say
you don't think two seconds is a long
time you don't think half a second is a
long time okay sit there right now count
two seconds count half a second now take
your stove at home make it as hot as
possible put your cheek on that stove
count half a second half a second can be
a very very long time in an active
shooting scenario that can be a very
long time just that struggle with this
hero tate meyer is the name i want you
to remember it
now why does that matter
we can't quantify the amount of lives
saved
just like with firearms when people are
talking about gun control right now if
you look at the number of shootings
people who are killed by firearms the
united states they take away suicides
it's anywhere between 12 to 20 000 a
year
okay there are on the low end 500 000
to over 2 million
defensive uses of firearms each year and
the huge majority of them never require
a shot fired you don't know how many
lives are saved by someone
bringing up their concealed carry saying
all right cut it out
you don't know how many people are pro
they stop rapes they stop muggings you
don't know how many people get killed
when there's a mugging you have no idea
if someone says go on the allen get on
your knees if he plans to take your
watch or if he plans to kill you so what
i am saying is we know that there are
far far more defensive uses of firearms
than violent certainly offensive violent
uses of firearms and you can't even
quantify how that could be
exponentially more live saved than just
the simple defensive deployment of a
firearm and these are statistics that
are not even these are not argued all
references available at
lotterycredit.com so i want when people
say this is what bothers me and people
say why don't you care about these kids
no no why don't you want to do something
that actually helps these kids so here's
what i want to get to um
94
94 of mass shootings occur in gun-free
zones there is no other more significant
uh significant correlating statistic
what i will say bothers me is when
people come out and you'll have these
people who say hey you know what uh
these kids were on psychotropic drugs
you'll hear some podcasts so let's do
that like look i get that we over
prescribe but sometimes these kids are
disturbed and so they are offered
medication so don't blame prozac don't
blame i'm not saying that all kids
should be on it but that's also lazy
these same people say correlation
doesn't equal causation why do you think
he was on psychotropic drugs and it
still is nowhere clear to 94
of mass shootings occur in gun-free
zones yes a lot of them don't have debts
people will say well a lot of them maybe
were in poor areas nope you can't really
say there's a correlation the strongest
and it's undeniable
94 of all mass shootings take place in
gun-free zones okay now
the country's own term is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard anyway yeah it's
like what do you want to do make the
signs bigger you think that was the
problem they were like oh i was gonna do
it but gun freeze though right gun free
well a gun-free zone or as a mass
shooter sees it
target practice yeah because everybody
there doesn't have a gun i know and
people say well what do you think you're
gonna be rambo if you had a gun uh and
fight back oh you know what to give you
a fighting chance here let's change
let's change the scenario really quickly
why the extreme yeah why the extreme
let's change that scenario that was a
teacher there in that classroom at the
door now apparently it actually was a
sheriff who used the or deputy law
enforcement officer right use the word
bro
ugh
so anyway um
let's say that was the shooter because
it actually does happen
teacher has a gun problem solved
do you honestly think you think it
requires rambo coming out of the river
no someone to the door saying uh land
shark let me in bang bang bang now
people get offended at this idea of
teachers being able to carry firearms
i'd i'm not saying that it will solve
i'm not saying that we will no longer
have mass shootings what i'm saying is
that okay let's look at the data 94
percent of mass shootings occur in gun
free zones and many schools are gun free
zones nearly all public schools
depending on state law but then it's
also usually punted to the principle and
we all know that uh
public education administrative
officials are not necessary it's not
necessarily a bastion of conservatism
exactly so what i am saying is it would
give that teacher absolutely a fighting
chance contrast with the gun control
proposals right now that you see from
the left and they do this under the
guise of caring
i've seen stats as low as 300 something
million guns in the united states and
i've seen stats that show it's actually
gotten over 400 the only way that the
gun control proposals which you will see
on twitter instagram facebook youtube
right now which they trend because of
the algorithms
unbiased right neutral algorithms
absolutely my cpu is a learning computer
right a neural net [ __ ]
so
when you look at those trends
i have no idea
the only way for their proposals to work
is if
all of america is a gun-free zone
if there are any guns we have 400
million
let's say you reduce it down to 50
million
that would not stop mass shootings
that would not that would not make a
dent and does anyone here actually think
we could get rid of
two-thirds of half the guns in the
united states of america this is also
what's funny when you hear people argue
against the drug war and they say well
you know it'll put drug dealers out of
business right they won't move to arms
or underage sex trafficking drug dealers
the cartel they don't see themselves in
the business of drugs they see
themselves in the business of not paying
taxes whatever they can sell illegally
to be clear so the only way that these
current proposals coming from the left
could help is if the entire united
states if the entirety of the country
was a gun free zone and we all agreed
okay that problem got away from us yeah
no more guns guys
and by the way that's exactly what they
want
they're not argue you think the
difference here is the fact that the guy
had a 15-round magazine and not a 10.
yeah you think that that's the
difference you don't think that do you
have any idea how quick
how quickly you can reload a magazine
that would make no difference do you
think whether it's a pistol grip or a
rifle grip would have made a difference
no it absolutely would have would not
look at the assault weapons ban look at
these cosmetic differences look at the
gun control proposals even a red flag
law wouldn't have stopped it because the
kid was 15 and i'm going on the
information that we have now let me ask
you this if that shooter was at that
door and that teacher had a gun do you
think it would make a difference of
course you would yeah absolutely i want
my son to go to a school and i want the
first day of school hey guys just to
make sure everybody's protected we want
you to know if anybody comes on campus
there are three
armed people on this campus at all times
and you will not know who they are if
something happens we've got you covered
yeah one it tells the kids they're safe
two it tells anybody who wants to try to
bring a gun to school
they're armed yeah and you won't know
who they are well here's also the
problem in michigan you are a lot
teachers are technically allowed to
carry under circumstances this includes
possession of a non-concealed firearm by
an individual licensed to carry a
concealed weapon possession with the
permission of the school's principal or
an agent of the school designated by the
school's principal or the school board
so here's something the school
potentially i don't know what happened
with the principal had the capacity
to not make them sitting ducks but
didn't do anything about it i don't
understand well you think the solution
is to arm all teachers no i do not i do
not want to thrust upon a teacher who
goes ooh again i don't want that guy
anywhere near firearm i think he's a
danger but i don't know why
they don't all have the capability to do
that right i mean it's just not in
everybody it's not ingrained in people
to do that it's absolutely not some
people can't even shoot a student if
they know them you know like that's
there's a lot of layers to it right but
there are people that are capable in
that building and i don't know why we
forbid them the right that we afford
everybody else when someone says so you
think the solution is to arm all
teachers no i think it's to not forbid
certain teachers the right to
self-defense i don't know why you think
it's more absurd for a teacher to have a
locked loaded safe firearm in a
classroom than a cashier to have one on
his hip then someone on the factory line
to have one carrying appendix stuff i i
i don't know why can you comment can
people let me know what's the argument
that it's more absurd well the kids will
take it
okay you have it locked if it's if you
can't have protocols in place or if the
teacher is carrying it himself there are
retention holsters that make it
impossible in a loaded check and a
liquor store there's a reason for it
yeah and i mean even with schools and
i've always thought this and people can
disagree but the reason why i think
metal detectors are a good thing it's
not because the shooter's not just gonna
run in it's just the fact that you see a
detourant every single day
and if you had armed guards that were
right there it would detour you from
doing that if you add that to the people
inside that are willing to carry that's
fine and you can't look at this and go
well you know it really should just be a
gun-free zone gun-free school the
reality is that we no longer live in
that society we never did i wish i could
send my kid to a school where i didn't
have to worry about it getting shot up
but guess what no one in america with
children right now have that luxury so
we can either do something about it or
we can keep this
bs conversation going back and forth
about how we can't arm teachers yeah and
i'm somebody who 10 years ago and like i
said for us at least yeah when it hit
home was columbine because that's what
was glorified in the media
these weren't kids uh dylan klebel and
eric harris these weren't losers these
weren't unpopular kids one was a
sociopath one was following the other it
was a little bit different than what
kids get now which is endless streams of
your worthless stuff being thrown at you
the news telling you that violence is
the answer you're getting i can't
imagine being a kid right now going
through the most insecure part of your
life and being told that violence is
virtue by every single news source and
not ending up acting like this yeah
we're we are poisoning our children with
our media and this is the result of it
that's why you keep seeing these
shooting these shootings happen over and
over and over again it's not because it
just all of a sudden occurred it's
because they're being told to
subliminally and i firmly believe and
you know what i think i think it's well
put and i'll add one
one wrinkle to that i hate to use the
word layer that's like a word like
nuance like oprah don't do it club
should like what i like is layers layers
yeah if it's cake like clothing
well i prefer if she's wearing layers i
want her looking like a hollister dummy
in the winter season
so uh
the issue there too is kids aren't told
they're worthless kids feel worthless
now let me let me tell you guys why
we actually have a culture participation
trophies and we have a culture that
tells lizzo that she's healthy brave and
beautiful that all kids are wonderful
brave and beautiful but the reason kids
feel more worthless and hopeless than
ever is because
i was talking with my wife about this
the other day
there's only one way
one way to develop self-esteem
now there isn't a moral sense we talk
about this as a christian as esteeming
others first serving others first you'll
always feel better about yourself and
you'll always be more purposeful if you
help people but as far as feeling good
about yourself as a teenager or an adult
it's not a participation trophy it's not
lying to yourself convincing yourself
that you're brave and healthy lizzie
knows she's unhealth liz oh no she's
unhealthy
if a kid is to have self-esteem there's
one way that i know to do it get really
really good at something get excellent
at something
we've vilified excellence and we've told
everyone that you know what excellence
is just as good as mediocre you're all
great you know what you can't tell that
to a little boy
little boy doesn't believe it i'll tell
you that when i was a kid my dad god
bless him i know he's watching i love
you dad i would get my ass kicked i was
bullied a whole lot you know what he
tried to he saw this new thing ufc
brazilian jiu-jitsu so that's what we
have to learn cause i'd taken karate and
kung all the stuff that didn't work and
so he said we're going to teach you
jujitsu like why is gracie because he
knows being bullied and i went down to
the community center and it was the same
guy who taught the karate and the kung
fu was aikikai jitsuto that he made up
and here's the thing after that
my mom or my dad would say do you know
what you do to that bully you walk right
up to him and you tell him that he
better stop or else
and guess what
that doesn't work because i knew if i
said or else i get my ass kicked
when puss come push comes to shove i
didn't believe in myself because i knew
that i shouldn't believe in myself i had
never learned how to defend myself i had
never learned to fight so you can teach
kids words you can teach kids to feel
good about themselves but guess what
they know it's a lie and so when you
convince people to lie to themselves
like hey you're brave beautiful and
healthy like oh tommy you're actually a
girl like hey c-minus that's just as
good as an a like hey you know what it's
not your fault it's the fault of insert
privilege here and you try and develop
self-esteem that way guess what
it doesn't work because at the end of
the day that kid is lying to himself and
he knows it and so kids feel worthless
you wonder same reason right now look at
covid
what are kids able to get good we have a
we have a higher depression rate and
adolescents and teenagers first than
ever because they can't do anything they
can't accomplish anything you can't
develop self-esteem unless you
accomplish something it's that simple
look and you're being told to fight each
other and i'm sorry and i'm not
but i i just agree with you very much on
that point because when i was young i
was really good at drawing but that
didn't necessarily make you popular or
cool kind of a nerd my brother was an
athlete whatever so i learned that when
i played sports with people i just had
to be worse and they'd like me because
they were better than me and as i got
older that's what i learned is if i just
sat back and people were better they'd
be my friend right and then i got into
high school and my dad was always like
you love making films you love but then
you know it wasn't like every kid wanted
to make movies right it was my brother
calling me gay slurs you know every time
i have the video camera but then i got
into high school and i failed every
class but one class i had was tv
production yep all of a sudden i was
making movies and this teacher believed
in me and i started going to that class
and i was making all this stuff i was
going on the assembly playing like
bennett brower you know doing like the
news every single day from school you
know like as chris farley and it's like
this guy and and he may and he may not
never know it but
he's the only person that kept me in
school and in many ways may have saved
my life and my dad by telling me like no
you you are funny you have talents it's
just not what you think
it's not what you want them to think it
is because i started drinking and
partying to be popular and it and it
worked
it worked real well just like smoking
yeah yeah but that one thing though that
and now look where i am now though i
make sketches i'm on a show like
i wouldn't be anywhere in my life if
that teacher didn't sit me aside and
actually believe in me and i think a lot
of these kids you you just skim over any
talent that they have yeah if it's not
painfully obvious and and i think that's
the sad part is nobody said and i
remember this one teacher who ended up
if sorry if i'm rambling
but she was this one teacher who was in
a class and she was substituting for a
couple weeks
and she was an improv uh she told me
about second city and my dad had talked
about it yeah because she actually
thought i was really funny even though i
was just being the class clown dick
right and she goes you should take this
these classes you're actually funny she
goes you annoy the hell out of me but i
do have
she's like i do have to sometimes oh
she's honest yeah well years later i'm
i'm doing a motor city improv show and
my friend adam goes my wife's coming
today it was her and i was doing improv
with the teacher who told me that i
actually had value wow but it was two
people and all those all those years in
school that saw something in me when
everybody else called me a failure
brought me down to the office told me i
wasn't anything but here's the thing
that started with truth in other words
if that teacher said saw that you
weren't very popular and said hey no
you're good at uh hockey wouldn't have
helped you at all helped you because
she fostered something in you that was
true that she knew you could become good
at the problem is now we have so many in
trying to be fair we have teachers who
spend more time trying to convince a kid
who hasn't done anything
worthy of praise that they are worthy of
praise rather than finding the kids who
are either worthy of praise or trying to
develop something worthy of praise
that's the problem with the
participation trophy and i'm using that
just as an emblem that's the problem
with a society that says hey you know
what it's not about equal opportunity
it's about equity because guess what if
you try and enforce equity
you have to discard
this is why equity by the way the idea
of ensuring equity and i'm going to
leave on this the idea of ensuring
equity
comes from a marxist and when i say
marxist godless ideology you're right
when we come from we're talking about
guns here
look gun-free zone you know we've done
so many segments go watch i'm pro-gun
change my mind i think i've said all i
need to say about that if you believe
the [ __ ] they're peddling right now
there may be no hope for you go watch
those segments
but we are talking about
equi and this all stems from that
equity stems from marxism marxism is a
distinctly godless ideology and what
does that mean to ensure equity
you have to
you have to discard the idea of equal
opportunity you cannot have equality you
cannot have equal opportunity and ensure
equity one is about rigging the game one
is about deciding the winners and losers
and one is making sure that everyone
understands they are fearfully
wonderfully created by their god and
they have unalienable rights and they
have the right to pursue whatever it is
they want to pursue go nuts and let the
cards fall where they may when you say
we're going to ensure equity guess what
you're trying to fit
a square peg into a round hole and
convince
that square peg
that he's just as right for that round
hole as the next guy because you have to
ensure equity and guess what it's a lie
and it's a lie that people can't tell
themselves and so they feel worthless
and people who feel worthless become
desperate and desperate people commit
acts of gross evil and by the way
liberals leftists
i think that a lot of you i know that it
breaks your heart to see this too i'm
not assuming that you guys
don't care so don't assume that we don't
care what i mean what i'm not assuming
what i'm telling you
is that history all of it tells you that
your solutions are wrong and will lead
to more carnage and that's why i oppose
it all right before we go to mug club
right here please smash that like button
if sorry went off the rails here today
it's a little bit emotional tired of the
[ __ ] you can comment below
if you want to see more of it uh we are
going to go to mug club in just one
second we are going to play to lighten
up they don't make them like they used
to oh and today we're going to be
playing uh
we're going to be playing it with play
misti for me here's a teaser
he's an all-night disc jockey what does
this request really mean
for clint eastwood an invitation to
terror
i hope he likes what he sees when he
walks in here
because that's what he's taking to hell
with him just hope we're lucky enough to
grab her the next time she tries it
tries what
to kill you
the next scream you hear will be your
own
glenn eastwood play misty for me
this is going to be fun it involves
domestic abuse
because i'm not married the best kind
that is the mom from wrestle development
youtube i'm sure i've said enough that
you have to process right now with your
school of shitty moderators piss off
so